[Musique]
comment expliquer la mort j'ai visité 82
pays
j'ai vécu dans 12 mai arrivée ici en
trois jours je me suis senti chez moi
j'aime le froid j'aime la culture russe
j'aime cette histoire j'aime tout ici
ils se considèrent russe s'il ya une
guerre il se battra pour la russie
elle est pour certains c'est un peu
paradoxal peut-être que je suis un peu
toc et et que je pense comme un russe
mais ce pays est captivant pour moi
c'est un russe avec un passeport
britannique
j'ai décidé de déménager ici parce que
je sentais je savais que je pourrais
commencer une nouvelle vie ici
il est russe ça ne fait aucun doute je
suis john copie skiff un fermier russe
[Musique]
il ya combien de temps il ya trente
minutes environ
wuala il est né il y a trente minutes
regardez il ne peut pas encore marcher
ioulia est notre vache r c'est la
responsable elle les aime
ce sont tous ces enfants les humains
sont une espèce faible n'est ce pas nous
ne sommes pas capables de marcher
pendant deux ans mais lui en trente
minutes sa vie commence jeune match et
marc royaume uni le 17 juillet 1949 un
fils né dans la famille de yann copie
ski immigrant polonais et frida marjorie
chaume les anglaises si la famille était
déjà international ses parents
n'auraient jamais pu prévoir qu'un jour
leurs enfants deviendrez russe je suis
russe je suis un immigrant dans ce pays
mais je suis russe
c'est ma maison et si quelqu'un a
quelque chose à redire à ça qu'ils se
regardent d'abord dans la glace john vit
ici dans le village de croûte au bout
dans la région de vladimir
ce n'est pas sa maison c'est un hôtel
john l'a construit pour les touristes
lui il a décidé de s'installer dans une
ancienne étable
aujourd'hui c'est ici que j'habite en
russe ça s'appelle périchole mec ce qui
veut dire couloir entre deux cours au
cnic deux étapes dans cette salle se
trouvaient le matériel pour la traite
des chèvres
c'est là que nous avons commencé notre
vie agricole il y à plus de 26 ans mon
ardeur
si vous regardez le plafond vous verrez
que c'est un toit des tables classique
normal c'est notre maison john vendait
de l'acier et il a vécu et travaillé
dans 12 pays riche beau et prospère il
est allé en russie pour la première fois
en décembre 1991 pour un voyage
d'affaires de 3 jours
les temps étaient difficiles l'union
soviétique s'était dissoute il y avait
de longues files d'attentes devant
toutes les épiceries il n'attendait pas
grand chose de ce voyage je suis arrivé
ici en m'attendant à voir de rudes
soviétique vigoureux à cou de taureau
est complètement ivre c'était le cliché
c'était intéressant et les gens après la
pérestroïka tout le monde était très
amicale parce qu'une nouvelle vie
commençait le capitalisme n'était pas
encore arrivé les gens avaient plus de
temps libre je m'étais rendu dans
quelques bars puis quand je suis
retourné chez moi j'ai démissionné ai
dit que je voulais aller en russie
j'ai sauté sur cette occasion j'avais 42
ans à l'époque je me sentais chez moi
tout simplement
aujourd'hui john copie ce qui possède
l'une des plus grandes fermes de russie
elle compte plus de quatre mille vaches
et produit 50 tonnes de lait par jour
d'après crt
les vaches sont comme les femmes elles
sont toutes différentes
celle ci donne 4 litres et celle-là 8
regarder elle a un petit pays mais elle
donne ça ce litre c'est une vache en or
c'est pourquoi nous investissons
beaucoup dans cette vache nous achetons
la meilleure semences c'est la génétique
je suis gros et vous êtes mince c'est
génétique
cette vache donne 15 litres de lait
voilà une héroïne
les gens pensent que plus le pied gros
plus il ya de l'est mais non c'est juste
un set chose
elles sont comme les femmes sont
capricieuses le plus important est
d'assurer leur confort de les nourrir et
leur donner un bon endroit pour dormir
et si elle s'y plaisent bien
on obtient du lait une sérénade et comme
toutes les femmes elle écoute ne dit
rien elle fait son affaire
et puis s'en va il a fallu un certain
temps à john pour devenir agriculteur au
début ils vendaient de l'acier du
charbon en russie il était même co
propriétaire d'une mine de charbon pour
ce britannique libre et riche
la vie était insouciante facile jusqu'au
jour où il a décidé de tout laisser
derrière lui pour acheter un kolkhoze
abandonné puis un autre
mais john ne serait peut-être jamais
devenu fermier sans elle
[Musique]
j'étais un homme libre et je pense que
dieu a décidé que je ne devais pas
l'être donc dans les trois mois après
mon déménagement
j'étais dans un bar sur la paire sky à
un homme libre j'ai regardé autour de
moi et vu une grande jeune femme blonde
j'ai pensé je vais lui offrir un verre
et j'ai fait un pas en arrière en
reculant john m'a marché sur le pied et
a dit sorry il ne m'a pas vu parce qu'il
est très grand puis il s'est tourné vers
moi et j'ai dit oh je suis vraiment
désolé par les anglais et elle a répondu
bien sûr
et alors j'ai dit ah je suis désolé puis
je vous offrir un verre est encore une
fois bien sûr ce sont les deux seulement
qu'elle connaissait à l'époque il ya
bien sûr que j'en savais plus notre
éducation et est bonne après tout droit
puis tout s'est passé si vite
j'avais une belle vie pour être honnête
j'avais un appartement une voiture
c'était très bien une vie prospère
agréable sans attaches et puis se marier
juste comme ça tout de suite c'était
carrément une demande en mariage il n'en
démord départ j'ai demandé veux-tu
l'épousé elle a dit j'ai besoin de
réfléchir et il a réfléchi longtemps ne
dort pas longtemps deux ou trois mois tu
as longtemps effectivement
[Musique]
oui car nous avons appris à nous
connaître assez rapidement j'avais
beaucoup de questions je voulais
absolument savoir ce qu'elle faisait
quand elle était jeune etc
et puis j'avais ce stéréotype vous savez
j'étais un homme d'affaires étranger et
j'avais entendu parler de ces sacrés
russe john est venu me voir bouleversé
et a dit tu sais j'ai entendu dire que
toutes les femmes russes étaient avec
des étrangers pour l'argent et je lui ai
répondu oui mais oui john et nous c'est
juste à cause de l'argent
les anglaises elle vous aime
certainement sans argent et il a dit je
suis allé chez nina un jour j'ai ouvert
son album photo et j ai trouvé les
photos d'une fille normale de 13 ans qui
va dans le nord avec ses chiens fait du
ski dans les montagnes du caucase ce
fait la fête avec ses amis
j'ai presque pleuré de honte à cause de
mes horrible préjugés ses partenaires
russes lui disais que j'étais un agent
du kgb
encore une fois il est venu me voir
affligé tu sais ce qu'ils disent de toi
et moi j'ai dit d'accord je suis du kgb
et quoi alors qu'est ce que ça peut te
faire il a dit ah oui bon oui en fait ça
va vous vous disputez souvent tous les
jours tout le temps comme tous les jours
c'est juste que john ne cède jamais sans
se battre il aime ce processus je pense
que les occidentaux sont très romantique
je suis un romantique un matin au ton
s'est dit bye bye
et puis j'entends celle où la porte
s'est refermée
j'étais encore à 20 mètres de la
barrière elle m'a tout de suite oublier
elle a dû se dire dieu merci les parties
je peux enfin boire un café et regarder
un film
la seule chose que j'ai promise à johnny
quand je l'épousé c'était qu'ils ne
s'ennuient réparé je crois que je vais
mais il ne pouvait pas savoir
non elle a dit qu'il y aurait cinq
enfants et qu'il devrait sauver la
patrie
[Musique]
des tirs sur cinq enfants tous
différents à fallouja cinq c'est bien
mieux qu'un ou deux c'est plus facile
d'une certaine façon vous devenez plus
rationnel qu'avant car si quelque chose
ne va pas avec l'un d'eux un autre vous
réjouira pas dit que maman est gentil et
maman dit que papa est gentil si vous ne
faites pas n'importe quoi ils le sont
tous les deux la carotte et le bâton
ça a été notre éducation maman était
moins indulgente
il y avait toujours un impératif avec
elle va pas pouvez nous donner un bonbon
quand personne ne regardait nous étions
nombreux pas le temps de discuter ils
étaient 2 nous étions 5
donc c'était soit nous soit si je fais
quelque chose qu'ils ne veulent pas que
je fasse je m'assure qu'elle n'en savent
rien ils n'ont donc aucune raison de me
gronder si on rate quelque chose maman
plaisante en disant que c'est parce que
nous sommes anglo saxons
par exemple si j'ai de mauvaises notes à
l'école elle dit voilà c'est ton sens
anglo-saxon ça tous les enfants les
aident à la ferme mais les filles vont à
l'école alors elle ne peuvaient dès que
les week-ends et les jours fériés
les fils ne travaille tout le temps
ce n'est pas assez pour la salle de
vêlage ce n'est pas assez le fils aîné
stéphane travaille aussi à la ferme mais
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
il a passé beaucoup de temps en exil
dans le pays d'origine de son père il a
commencé à critiquer sa patrie il disait
la russie est un pays de merde on lui a
dit et bien vers l'occident libre alors
mais ne compte pas sur notre aide
financière que je lui donnais une petite
somme d'argent
je les emmenais abbas et lui ai proposé
tu n'aimes pas la russie vit ici j'ai
pris son passeport russe est dit et bien
à plus tard je penserai qu'il me
financerait qui me soutiendrait quand je
suis allé là bas mais on m'a dit vas-y
débrouille toi je devais tout faire moi
même
au début j'étais serveurs car je ne
pouvais pas trouver d'autre travail ont
si peu de temps je suis devenu gérant de
bar et après j'ai déménagé à londres
il travaillait dans un bar les gens le
pointer du doigt et disait voilà le
russe vous voyez il ne sourit jamais et
lui mais vous me prenez pour un idiot
pour quoi sourire quand je grillons tous
les la prochaine fois vous allez
déguster et bien je voulais revenir au
bout d'un mois
mais j'ai dû me forcer à faire un nouvel
essai mais non ils errent toujours en
souriant comme des imbéciles nous ne
soyons pas n'importe qui ici si votre
voisin un problème vous essayer d'aider
parce que c'est votre voisin là bas si
votre voisin est en difficulté c'est son
problème
il vous sourire ont et continueront à
s'occuper de leurs propres affaires
les gens ne le comprenais pas il le
taquinaient et au bout de trois ans il
s'est plaint à sa mère je vais rejoindre
l'armée je vais aller en sibérie je veux
revenir à la maison c'était son choix
john est heureux il ne le cache pas son
fils a choisi la russie et john à fait
les mêmes fois en 1991 il lui a fallu
six ans pour devenir citoyen russe
à cette époque les services de sécurité
russes étaient suspicieux à l'égard d'un
britannique qui voulait obtenir un
passeport russe
mais marine témérité ça c'était en 1997
à l'époque tout le monde voulait partir
et cet idiot est arrivé il voulait vivre
ici j'ai eu un entretien avec les agents
du kgb
ils sont venus me voir et m'ont demandé
pourquoi voulez vous vivre en russie
moi j'ai dit pour 6 pour ça ils ont dit
m
vous pas peur de la mafia j'ai dit j'ai
la meilleure kreesha qu'ils soient ils
ont demandé c'est qui j'ai répondu dieu
tout puissant
cela fait longtemps que john parle de la
russie en usant de termes comme notre
peuple
mon pays il va rarement au royaume uni
il s'ennuie vite là bas et les relations
avec sa famille britannique sont
devenues compliquées
j'ai des frères et soeurs au royaume
mieux que je sois parti ne leur plaît
pas je pense que cela les a agacé quand
je leur ai parlé pour la dernière fois
il y a quelques années et que j'ai dit
et bien nos enfants se verront à la
frontière s'il ya un conflit si l'otan
arrive à la frontière le fils de ma
soeur peut s'y retrouver alors que ma
fille sera de l'autre côté ils ne
comprennent pas cela en tant que
britannique
je ne fais plus allégeance à ce pays
j'ai trop de colère et de déception
j'aime être ici et c'est difficile à
comprendre pour les gens ils ont la
démocratie ils ont la liberté
mais qu'est ce que c'est cette liberté
d'aujourd'hui la liberté est un droit de
dire ce que vous voulez pas de détruire
quoi que ce soit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi ils ont dégradé la statue de
winston churchill
je n'en sais rien et je pense que c'est
stupide je pense que ce sont des
émotions sans fondement l'histoire c'est
l'histoire est peut-être que ces
monuments sont là pour nous rappeler ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire bon c'est qu'il
ya eu l'esclavagé et s'il n'y avait pas
eu d' esclavage il ne serait pas en
amérique c'est un peu hypocrite à mon
avis le passé c'est le passé
vous ne pouvez pas le modifier
l'histoire est une leçon il faut la
prendre
toute personne qui veut être cultivé
doit comprendre l'histoire sans dans son
pays que dans le monde entier
c'est notre coin rouge oui mon mariage
est très intéressant car pour ma femme
je suis sa troisième ou quatrième
priorité décrypte à perdre je viens au
premier poteau
la russie qui monsieur staline je
suppose que je suis à la quatrième place
non seulement son opinion de staline est
biaisé mais c'est le cas chez de
nombreux étrangers à qui nous avons
parlé il faut 20 minutes pour expliquer
pourquoi et comment
après quoi ils disent wow nous n'avions
jamais pensé comme ça il est bon et la
belle et très patriotique
je ne peux rien dire de mal sur la
russie êtes vous aussi un admirateur de
staline
non je ne le suis pas uniquement de dieu
nina viens d'une famille de militaires
voilà pourquoi c'est aussi important
pour elle le coin rouge est en fait
consacrée à l'histoire du kolkhoze que
johnny nina ont acheté mais staline est
une personnalité historique si
controversé qu'il est en permanence
l'objet de discussions et la famille
copine ce qui ne fait pas exception
pour ce qui est de l'histoire c'est
comme du kung fu parce que maman aime ça
je dirais même qu'elle attend ces débats
moi je n'aurais pas aimé vivre en urss
j'aime les chaussures adidas ce genre de
chose mais quoi qu'il en soit un
imbécile n'aurait pas pu donner à son
pays la victoire lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale pouvait penser ce que
vous voulez j'ai quand certains disent
des choses
qu'aurait-il fait lorsque vous avez des
millions de personnes qui ont besoin de
quelque chose à manger de vêtements de
travail
il n'y a rien d'autre à faire il faut
être sévère pour encourager le peuple à
faire de telles choses mais gaspillé des
vies humaines ce n'est pas bien
maman et pour comment ça s'appelle le
communisme franchement je suis souvent
d'accord avec elle mais bien sûr c'est
un pays hypocrite est né dans une
famille riche et pensé que ce serait
génial de vivre le socialisme mamans et
papas sont prêts à céder tout ça à
l'état
je suis sérieux là
[Musique]
c'est le fromage est pire qu'une femme
c'est très capricieux il faut sentir
chaque étape une autre passion de john
le fromage bien sûr ils utilisent
uniquement le lait de sa propre ferme
c'est de l'amour c'est de la patience
john a commencé à faire du fromage il y
a 6 ans lorsque l'europe et les états
unis ont imposé des sanctions à la
russie en réponse la russie a interdit
d'importer certains produits ce qui
était une bonne nouvelle pour jane je
pense que les sanctions étaient une
bonne chose pour nous et je pense que
cela a d'abord permis aux gens de
retrouver leur fierté d'être russe nous
l'avions perdu en quelque sorte
aujourd'hui nous avons cet embargo
contre eux et ils introduisent pas de
sanction contre nous parce qu'ils ont
perdu beaucoup plus jeunes fait
différents fromages
il va nous en montrer fait intéressant
il a donné son nom à l'un de ses
fromages
john et zen et de durmenach c'est john
than il est déjà affiné 5,7 mois dure
comme une brique ce sont tous des
chambres balla cheddar
c'est un fromage italien tu la quête
shota celui ci s'appelle octobre rouge
il ya du saindoux à l'intérieur ici il
ya de la bonne moisissures qui se
développe deux types de poivre annexes
c'est juste du fromage nature mais c'est
ma recette spéciale ce fromage s'appelle
camarades parce que nina a dit qu'il
avait le goût d'un fromage soviétique
d'autres fois c'est une expérience
c'est mieux que le parmesan
et de glisser un peu brûlé n'est ce pas
un peu oui
au travail tout le monde l'appelle john
ianovitch ils ont réussi clés sont
anglais il ya longtemps
monsieur john ça ne me plaît pas oncle
jeunes non plus nos vrais deuxième
prénom et maxwell d'où il vient je n'en
ai aucune idée
vous savez en occident au royaume uni
vous pouvez donner un deuxième prénom à
votre enfant en vous inspirant d'une
équipe de football
ça n'a aucun sens pour moi qu'on
respecte ses parents en russie est
important le patronyme est la
continuation de la tradition familiale
vous prenez le nom de votre père je suis
donc john ianovitch ce qui veut dire que
je suis fils de jan et j'en suis très
fier john le prix de l'orge a commencé à
baisser
il nous faut 100 tonnes consultez les
offres je suis si fatiguée du mieux on
ça marche ou pas non ça ne marche pas
macha puis-je avoir un peu de là s'il te
plaît il est très exigeant il a beaucoup
d'idées de projets nous n'arrivons pas
toujours à le suivre
ça va parfois trop vite c'est pour ça
que nous le payons s'il n'est pas
content c'est un idiot mais john
ianovitch est un gestionnaire exigeant
qui peut faire une inspection surprise
en pleine nuit c'est la tour de contrôle
ils savent que j'ai mon système
la nuit quand les lumières sont allumées
ou éteintes
il pense qu'il ya peut-être quelqu'un là
haut c'est ça la discipline ses sabots
sont mauvais non elle a d'importantes
grosser sur les jambes
d'accord je vais me fâcher ils doivent
comme ça voilà pauvre m il faut creuser
plus par là mais le plus dur est pour
ses fils c'est difficile pour eux de
travailler avec leur père mais
apparemment c'est mieux que de vivre en
angleterre
[Musique]
je suis un bourreau de travail
je me lève à 5 heures je me couche à une
heure du matin je suis dédié à mon
entreprise
à quelle heure et tu arrivé au travail
aujourd'hui vers 8 heures à 8 heures
c'était vers 7 heures auparavant j'ai
été au garage avant le service des
voitures d'accord il ouvre à quelle
heure 7h30 ou 8h tu vois là c'est tu
dois être ici en premier quand ils
viennent au travail tu leur dis il faut
faire ça ça et ça ne leur demande pas de
te signaler cela de nos jours un leader
doit être le premier saisir je comprends
et bien la porte est juste là voilà
pourquoi devrais-je être gentil ce n'est
pas de l'amour c'est le patron mais il a
un bouton qui active la fonction papa
tout le monde a ses propres opinions
et ça n'est pas toujours facile de le
lui dire parfois il vaut mieux juste
garder son sang froid
c'est un homme adulte après tout j'ai un
autre côté s'il n'était pas mon père il
vous donne une tâche et si vous échouez
une fois deux fois alors c'est fini mais
comme c'est notre père
il peut nous aider ou nous conseiller
s'il est de bonne humeur et puis il a
énormément d'expérience
bon
notre passion familiale les chevaux
seulement des races russe bien sûr il
dirige une école d'équitation et un
centre d'équithérapie mais ce ne sont
pas les seules sources de revenus de
john
et voilà ici c'est de l'or mais deux ans
et de l'or le diplôme où les gens
viennent acheter cet or à kouba est très
bon pour les rosiers il possède
également des troïkas russes
traditionnelles conduire un tel attelage
est une compétence qu'on enseigne
rarement de nos jours c'est très
compliqué et pas du tout populaires mais
les copies ce qui ressuscite cette
vieille tradition qu'est ce qu'une
trouille caris pour vous c'est un ordre
de ma femme
mieux vaut investir dans une troïka que
dans une rolls royce c'est notre choix
c'est notre vision de la richesse si
demain il n'y a plus de pétrole en
arabie saoudite ou en russie nous
pourrons toujours nous déplacer comme ça
mais moi j'ai été labouré et fauché et
labouré bref tout nous avons une vision
différente de la richesse quand j'ai
demandé à nina de m'épouser
elle a dit ai parlé je vais y réfléchir
j'ai besoin de parler à mon prêtre il
m'a dit c'est bizarre c'est un étranger
par quels sont ses croyances à quoi ça
va rimer groupe est alors j'ai répondu à
john au téléphone le prêtre dit que tu
devrais te convertir à l'orthodoxie pour
que ça soit ça j'ai dit je crois en dieu
il n'y a pas de problème je cherche dieu
donc je vais me faire baptiser
nous sommes allés à l'église saint-jean
le guerrier sur l'avenue ligne ce qui
ont m'a dit de me déshabiller on m'a
donné une chemise blanche et j'ai été
baptisé
il ya 15 ans nous avons commencé à
construire cette église
elle est consacrée aux femmes qui ont
découvert en premier que le christ est
ressuscité ne plaisantons à ce sujet
parce qu'en russe ça se prononce alors
jeune lire no 7
quand j'ai entendu cela j'ai cru que
c'était johnny renault cède ce qui est
john myhre no 7
en fait ce sont les miro fort
[Musique]
j'ai toujours cru en dieu mais
honnêtement l'église catholique me
faisait peur en russe nous avons ce mot
rare bougies il a peur de dieu quand
j'étais catholique je n'avais vraiment
peur d'aller à l'église chaque fois que
j'y entrais j'avais l'impression que la
foudre allait me frapper si je faisais
quelque chose de mal j'aime l'orthodoxie
fais ce que j'aime
ainsi comme dans beaucoup de choses en
russie c'est qu'il n'ya pas d'hypocrisie
je ne pense pas que je devrais justifier
pourquoi je suis croyant pour moi même
si vous ne l'êtes pas les dix
commandements sont de benoît pour tout
le monde
selon lesquelles il faut vivre surtout
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'aime ma maison ici et je pense que
toute personne qui veut venir ici sera
la bienvenue et où vraiment ce n'est pas
de la propagande
on ne me paie pas pour dire ça fort
heureusement ou malheureusement peu
importe
et c'est un grand pays aux horizons
infinis à la gêne ses immenses
perspectives
là où il ya un horizon infini il y a
toujours du potentiel
j'étais un robot quand je suis arrivé
ici j'étais un homme d'affaires
international capitaliste typique voyage
en neuf mois par an dormans quatre
heures par nuit
je crois que je suis devenu ici un homme
beaucoup plus agréable ap suis je
heureux bien sûr que je le suis je ne
pensais pas un jour avoir 70 ans je ne
pensais jamais voir le jour où la plus
jeune de mes filles auraient 15 ans la
russie m'a donné une longue vie j'ai
tout ce que je veux mon seul rêve est
que tous mes enfants trouvent eux aussi
un aussi grand bonheur que celui que
j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
e